T
ALLOWED BACK ON TWITTER.
SENATE MINORITY LEADER MITCH
McCONNELL HAS BEEN AN
OUTSPOKEN CRITIC OF PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S AFGHANISTAN EVACUATION
CALLING IT A, QUOTE, BOTCHED
EXIT.
THE SENATE MINORITY LEADER JOINS
US NOW.
SENATOR McCONNELL, THANKS FOR
BEING HERE.
>> GLAD TO BE WITH YOU, BRET.
>> Bret: WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
YOU SAW THE PRESIDENT'S SPEECH
YESTERDAY.
YOU HAVE SEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO TALK
ABOUT HOW THEY SAID THEY WERE
PREPARED FOR EVERY CONTINGENCY
AND HAVE YOU SEEN THE IMAGES
COMING OUT OF THE KABUL ERRANT.
>> WELL, FIRST, LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE DECISION TO WITHDRAWAL
ITSELF.
WE WERE SPENDING ABOUT 1% OF THE
PENTAGON BUDGET EVERY YEAR TO
KEEP THE LID ON IN AFGHANISTAN.
WE HADN'T LOST A SINGLE AMERICAN
SOLDIER IN COMBAT IN THE LAST
YEAR.
IT WAS WORKING.
IT WAS WORKING BECAUSE WE WENT
THERE, WE WENT THERE TO PREVENT
AL QAEDA FROM BEING BACK IN FULL
OPERATIONAL MODE UNDER THE
TALIBAN AND TO SORT OF KEEP THE
LID ON.
MY GUESS IS WE'RE GOING TO END
UP SPENDING WAY MORE TRYING TO
EVACUATE PEOPLE WITH THIS
SLIPSHOD OPERATION.
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT.
IT'S A STAIN ON OUR NATIONAL
REPUTATION.
THEY'RE UP TO 15,000 AMERICANS
STRANDED OUT IN THE COUNTRY WHO
PRESUMABLY HAVE TO BEG THE
TALIBAN TO LET THEM GET TO THE
AIRPORT, NOT TO MENTION THE
INTERPRETERS WHO WORKED WITH US
AND OTHER AFGHANS WHO ARE IN
DANGER BECAUSE THEY COOPERATED
WITH US.
ALL OF THIS IS THE AFTERMATH OF
THE DECISION FIRST TO WITHDRAWAL
AND TO WITHDRAWAL IN A
PRECIPITOUS AND INCOMPETENT WAY.
>> Bret: I WANT TO GET TO THAT
DECISION TO WITHDRAWAL BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WAS IN THE SAME
PLACE.
BUT HAS THIS ADMINISTRATION, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BEEN
FORTHCOMING WITH BRIEFINGS TO
CONGRESS ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
NOW?
WERE THEY FORTHCOMING WITH
BRIEFINGS ABOUT THEIR PLANNING
ON WHAT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN?
>> YEAH.
WELL, LOOK, THIS IS ENTIRELY
PREDICTABLE.
I, FOR ONE, ALONG WITH OTHERS,
HAVE BEEN PREDICTING IT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WOULD HAPPEN.
THE ONLY QUESTION WAS HOW
QUICKLY WOULD IT HAPPEN?
AND I'M, FRANKLY, NOT SURPRISED.
THAT THERE IS A TOTAL COLLAPSE.
WHEN WE LEFT, OUR EUROPEAN
ALLIES LEFT, REMEMBER, THIS WAS
A NATO MISSION.
WE WEREN'T THERE ALONE.
NATO MISSION.
WHEN WE LEFT, OUR EUROPEAN
ALLIES LEFT.
THE PRESIDENT IMMEDIATELY SAID
WE'RE LEAVING QUICKLY.
THE AFGHAN MILITARY KNEW AT THAT
POINT THEY WERE ON THEIR OWN.
SO WE ARE BACK TO WHERE WE WERE,
BRET, BACK TO WHERE WE WERE
PRIOR TO 2011.
PRIOR TO 2001, AND THE 2011
ATTACK.
>> Bret: YEAH.
SENATOR, HERE'S THE PRESIDENT
TALKING ABOUT HOW HE BELIEVED
THAT ENEMIES WOULD WANT US TO
HAVE STAYED IN AFGHANISTAN AND
HE STICKS BY THIS DECISION.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> IF AFGHANISTAN IS UNABLE TO
MOUNT ANY REAL RESISTANCE TO THE
TALIBAN NOW, THERE IS NO CHANCE
THAT ONE YEAR, ONE MORE YEAR,
FIVE MORE YEARS, OR 20 MORE
YEARS OF U.S. MILITARY BOOTS ON
THE GROUND WOULD HAVE MADE ANY
DIFFERENCE.
OUR TRUE STRATEGIC COMPETITORS,
CHINA AND RUSSIA, WOULD LOVE
NOTHING MORE THAN THE UNITED
STATES TO CONTINUE TO FUNNEL
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN RESOURCES
AND ATTENTION INTO STABILIZING
AFGHANISTAN INDEFINITELY.
>> Bret: HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
THAT?
>> WELL, ONE THING WE KNOW FOR
SURE THE TERRORISTS AROUND THE
WORLD ARE CHEERING.
THEY ARE CHEERING.
THE TERRORISTS IN SYRIA, IN
IRAQ, IN YEMEN, IN AFRICA.
THEY'RE ALL WATCHING THE TALIBAN
FLAG FLY OVER THE CAPITAL IN
AFGHANISTAN.
OVER THE PRESIDENTIAL PALACE IN
KABUL.
THE TALIBAN HAS, IN EFFECT, IN
THEIR EYES, DEFEATED THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
IT'S AN UTTER EMBARRASSMENT.
OUR ALLIES WON'T TRUST US.
THIS WAS AN INCREDIBLY
INCOMPETENT STEP.
AND I'M GOING TO SAY PREVIOUS
PRESIDENTS HAVE WANTED TO LEAVE
AFGHANISTAN AS WELL BUT, IN THE
END THEY DIDN'T BECAUSE WE KNEW
WE HAD THE LID ON.
WE KNEW WE HAD HELD AL-QAEDA
DOWN.
AND THAT'S THE MOST WE COULD
HAVE HOPED FOR IN AFGHANISTAN.
NOBODY THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO
CREATE A JEFFERSONIAN WESTERN
STYLE DEMOCRACY THERE.
>> Bret: YEAH.
BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP, DEFINITELY,
IN HIS TERM, WANTED TO GET
ALL-AMERICAN TROOPS HOME.
IT WASN'T CLEAR HOW EXACTLY HIS
EXIT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN OTHER
THAN THEY WERE TRYING TO
NEGOTIATE FOR SOMETHING
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE SAW THE
OTHER DAY.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THIS MAP
WHERE YOU SEE THE TALIBAN
MOVEMENT OVER TIME, IT'S PRETTY
AMAZING WHAT HAPPENED REALLY IN
THE PAST 96 HOURS FOR THE
TALIBAN MOVEMENT.
AND THE "NEW YORK TIMES" IS
SAYING THAT THE INTEL WAS BEING
PRESENTED SAYING THAT IT WAS
CLEAR EVIDENCE OF A COLLAPSE OF
AFGHAN FORCES AFTER AMERICAN
OFFICIALS DECIDED TO MOVE OUT OF
THE 2500.
WHAT WAS -- THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, WHAT WOULD
REPUBLICANS HAVE DONE
DIFFERENTLY IF YOU WERE GOING TO
MOVE THOSE TROOPS OUT?
>> WELL, FIRST, AS I SAID, I
WOULDN'T HAVE LEFT.
I THINK THE POLICY WE WERE
PURSUING WAS WORKING.
IF YOU WERE GOING TO LEAVE, AT
LEAST YOU HAVE TO HAVE A GAME
PLAN TO TRY TO RESCUE THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN DANGERED BY THESE
BARBARIANS WHO ARE NOW IN CHARGE
OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> Bret: DO YOU HAVE ANY
CONSTITUENTS IN THERE?
>> THAT REQUIRES -- THAT
REQUIRES A LOT MORE PLANNING.
LOOK, THESE GUYS COULDN'T
ORGANIZE A TWO-CAR FUNERAL.
I CAN'T IMAGINE ANY -- THERE WAS
NO PLAN AT ALL.
AND YOU COULD SEE IT COMING.
THEY HAD PLENTY OF TIME TO AT
LEAST PLAN AN EVACUATION AND HAD
A CHANCE TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
SO FAR THIS EVACUATION HAS
FAILED.
>> Bret: SHOULD THE PRESIDENT BE
ASKING FOR RESIGNATIONS FROM HIS
NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM?
>> LOOK, I MEAN, THE PRESIDENT
CAN DECIDE WHO WORKS FOR HIM.
IT WAS HIS DECISION.
HE OWNS IT.
IT WAS A MISTAKE, MAJOR, MAJOR
PROPORTIONS.
>> Bret: ARE ANY OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IN AFGHANISTAN NOW?
>> I'M SORRY?
>> Bret: ANY OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IN AFGHANISTAN FROM
KENTUCKY?
>> I'M SORRY, I COULDN'T HEAR
YOU, BRET.
>> Bret: I'M JUST SAYING DO YOU
KNOW OF ANYBODY ON THE GROUND IN
AFGHANISTAN TRYING TO GET OUT?
ARE PEOPLE REACHING OUT TO YOUR
OFFICE?
I HAVE HEARD ANECDOTALLY SOME
SENATORS AND CONGRESSMAN ARE
TRYING TO HELP INDIVIDUALLY EVEN
THOUGH THE ADMINISTRATION IS
SAYING WE'RE NEGOTIATING WITH
THE TALIBAN TO LET THEM INTO THE
AIRPORT.
>> YEAH.
WE HAVE HEARD FROM PEOPLE IN
KENTUCKY WHO HAVE RELATIVES OVER
THERE WHO ARE VERY MUCH
CONCERNED ABOUT WHETHER THEY ARE
GOING TO GET OUT.
SO, REMEMBER, THERE ARE UP TO
15,000 AMERICANS OUT IN THE
COUNTRY CLAMORING TO GET TO THE
AIRPORT AND THEIR RELATIVES ALL
OVER AMERICA ARE QUITE CONCERNED
ABOUT THEIR SAFETY.
>> Bret: AND I JUST WANT TO ASK
YOU ONE THING ON THE PROCESS
GOING FORWARD ON THE OTHER SIDE,
THE BIG ISSUE, WHICH IS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL AND WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN WITH SPEAKER
PELOSI PUTTING FORWARD THIS BIG
$3.5 TRILLION PACKAGE AS YOU SEE
IT, WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN?
>> WELL, OF COURSE I'M HOPING
THAT 3.5 TO $5 TRILLION TAX
INCREASE IS GOING TO BE
DEFEATED.
THAT WILL BE DETERMINED WITHIN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
EVERY SINGLE REPUBLICAN IN THE
HOUSE AND SENATE IS TOTALLY
OPPOSED TO IT.
JUST GO BACK TO FEBRUARY OF
2020, WE HAD THE BEST ECONOMY IN
50 YEARS.
AND A BIG REASON FOR THAT WAS
THE 2017 TAX BILL.
THEY WANT TO TAKE THAT AND RIP
IT UP AND RAISE TAXES ON BIG
BUSINESSES, SMALL BUSINESSES,
ESTATES, HARDWORKING PEOPLE WHO
MAKE MUCH LESS THAN $400,000 A
YEAR.
IT'S A DEVASTATING BLOW TO THE
ECONOMY ON TOP OF THE INFLATION
WE ALREADY HAVE CREATED BY THE
BIG SPENDING FREE SPREE THAT
THEY ENGAGED IN EARLIER THIS
YEAR.
SO I THINK THEY'RE CLEARLY
TRYING TO TAKE THE COUNTRY IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION.
>> Bret: SENATOR McCONNELL, WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIM